so you have stretch marks and you want
to get rid of it well join the club
because there's actually a lot more guys
are there with stretch marks when you
think even in teens it's estimated that
40% of guys have stretch marks so can
you get rid of it and if you can how do
you do it well I'm gonna tell you so
let's start the video just very quick if
you're new here on my channel welcome
I'm Daniel and having a male model for
over 13 years and on this channel I give
you except that's got to do with
grooming style fitness and any men's
issues so consider subscribing and also
clicking that notification bell so you
won't miss any of the next videos now is
it possible to get rid of stretch marks
well to be honest it's one of the most
difficult skincare concerns out there to
deal with because there's no products on
the market that can get rid of stretch
marks completely but there is a few
things that can really help you out and
that's what I'm gonna talk about so
let's start with the first one
[Music]
first one is you can use a good quality
cream that contains retinol it's one of
the own ingredients that's shown to
improve the appearance of stretch marks
good options are dr. Dennis gross
anti-aging moisturizer and Paula's
Choice resist a lot of univita
description like always so you can go
and do your own research
now retinol is also found in good
quality anti-aging products because it
helps those fine lines and wrinkles the
way retinol works is that it builds
collagen making collagen bundles thicker
and healthier you can also get
prescription retinoids which is stronger
than the products of retinoids that you
get over the counter
[Music]
laser therapy laser therapy is one of
the best options out there I think it is
the best actually because it is backed
up by studies and it shows that people
who went for laser therapy days they saw
improvement in the appearance of their
scars between 50 and 75 percent which is
a lot now if you do want to take this
route you can go and see your
dermatologist because they'll be able to
help you out you don't have the money or
you feel uncomfortable with doing laser
therapy you can try chemical peels to be
specific TCA peels why TCA appeals well
because TCA peels penetrate further than
a AJ or bh8 peels so they are better at
stimulating collagen and elastin for the
depth of damage in the stretch marks not
just some last advice it's important to
keep your expectations realistic because
you won't be able to get rid of stretch
marks completely and remember those
stretch marks they're carrying your
story what you went through so for
example guys who were very heavily
overweight and you lost that weight then
you have those stretch marks and you
earned those stripes if you liked the
video give it a thumbs up subscribe and
I'll see you in the next video
you
[Music]